foreign
[Music]
my name is Brett may 41 years old we're
at Calipatria State Prison I'm in Elwood
life without the possibility of parole
and I've been incarcerated for 21 years
my name is Robert Ibarra I've been here
in calipat for since 2012. um and now
while being me as of and right now the
present but future of be free someday
soon
um my name is Jermaine wood I'm also
Center for elwar which is like without
the possibly parole
um I'm from Los Angeles California South
Central
um yeah when you get a sentence of life
without the passing the video of parole
see how I just exhaled right now it's an
invisible weight on your shoulders if
you're walking around in cement shoes
you're living in existence in a box with
guys that are coming in and going out
with their dates and and you don't have
one when I first came in this was what
20 years ago it was more for me like um
what do I have to look for like for us
we were The Last of the Mohicans it was
we got everything last jobs programs so
I was like what am I even like why
should I even care we have a older uh
brother within our community the brother
he's like uh in his 60s he's got a lot
of physical ailments and he's already
accepted the fact that he's gonna die in
prison he said something to the fact of
them putting his ashes in in a cup and
setting it up on a shelf in r r and it
sits there for two years and then it's
discarded because he has nobody out
there to snatch that it just like it
rocks you to the core like you get a
chance to Glimpse your future and
uh you cling to whatever type of uh
creature comfort that you might be able
to get a hold of just to make this place
more tolerable and then you wonder why
people seek a chemical Escape you know
individuals get lost in the drugs and
everything because they're looking for
some type of way to wrap their mind
around the fact that this is it you know
waking up every day with no expectation
of ever going home I was drinking a lot
I was drinking the drinking was what was
helping me continue
like you know I was just drinking till
probably more than likely I'll pass out
it wasn't about nobody else I didn't
care about what nobody else thought I
needed something to make me feel better
and that's where the violence came in at
well you know what I could tell you uh
from uh from my aspect right the days
were gloomy we it was mostly cell time
and when you're in your cell and a
little bit of yard that you have you you
don't have no kind of Outlet to to any
kind of positive programming so if
you're not in your cell trying to do
something constructive or positive then
you're gonna gravitate to to destructive
habits you know even just in the cell
and you're thinking and the way you
carry yourself what was the the nickname
of this prison back in the day
the nickname well I would think it'd be
all kind of nicknames you know I used to
refer to it as the Bermuda Triangle I
know uh I know it's still
you know uh got the reputation for you
know the violence and oh yeah yeah yeah
killer Pat and all yeah all the the
negativity and destruction and you know
the tension in the air you know was it
was always palpable you know I mean you
didn't go to the yard expecting to enjoy
your full yard you know
what does that do to you mentally it
gets you to you expect the unexpected if
you've accepted the fact that you're
gonna die in prison then you've already
accepted your worst fear so now what's
next I ain't really got nothing like so
you know taking hope away from an
individual and I don't wanna maybe I
phrase that wrong because nobody took it
you know I forfeit it that's right my
my um inalienable right of you know life
and Liberty like that was you know my
choices did that but having hope removed
from me you know stripped from my life
you know uh it can create a it can
create a dangerous individual with no
hope no it didn't matter and here
already coming to where we're already
labeled as like animals
you know forgotten about so we made
everything a battlefield nobody cares
about us
only one a person that can care about
you
is you
but at the same time you have to look at
it and think about it like do I really
care about myself yeah doing the stupid
[ __ ] that we were doing yeah I believe
that a lot of people are scared of
change because they don't know what's
going to happen right you give up
something you don't know and that's what
it is we we were scared to change you
get to the point where it's like
man I'm 40 years old [ __ ] I'm I've been
down this amount of time I've been doing
this I got kids I got wife I got
grandkids it ain't About You No More
it's not it's not you you need to start
focusing on making it better to make
sure that these people out here know
that you love them back for sure someone
could probably forgive you for something
that that you did to them but sometimes
if you if you're not understanding it's
hard for you to even forgive yourself
you know
um it's not that easy when you don't
understand a way or even how it took me
a long time to craft certain things and
understand certain things and I and I
know that these groups that I've been
involved with have given me a a stepping
stone because a lot of the groups are
spiritual you know God is intertwined in
all those groups you know I mean there's
no way that that anything good loving
caring kind of forgiving is not from him
you know everything that's good is from
him you know so he's all we've all in in
and out of the uh the curriculums you
know and I think there's a reason for
that and I think that most of us have
suffered some some form of traumas in
our past that make us suffer from um low
self-esteem you know where we don't
fully understand our value and and we're
living our life in such a way because
we're we're seeking approval you know
and acceptance and you know for me
especially when there were very very few
examples on the yard of that change to
step out and be one of those individuals
first at some point somebody has to step
out there and start
yeah prison teaches you to you know
treat relationships like they're
transactional well look I ain't messing
with dude if if I can't benefit from
them I wanna everything transactional
what do you got to give me we got to get
out of that way of thinking where
everything has to be beneficial to you
in the moment or you're looking for some
type of instant gratification in order
for you to even deal with this person or
do what it is that you're going to do so
when it comes to doing the work it can
be real discouraging real quick and you
can fall right back in to that same you
know frame of thinking or you can fall
into a rut and and come close to
becoming you know depressed and just
wallowing in in misery because you're
not seeing the direct fruits of the you
know of those labors or are you just
kind of like sit back and reflect and be
like you know what like
why should I even care my name is I'm
Rafael Acevedo I'm currently
associate Warrior and out of class
position over operations here at Cal
Patrick's Day prison I've been here for
26 years it's considered a maxim maximum
security cell living is predominantly in
threes and fours I'm wearing a 270
design meaning that the housing units
have 270 degrees of peripheral vision
from cell to cell 180 inmates higher
level security and that that's here
still no no 180s are other institutions
we're 270.
um so we're level four but we're the
lower part of a level four you've been
injured by prisoners before correct yeah
like multiple times correct I mean we
were in there was Calipatria had a lot
of incidents involving staff yeah yeah
calipatra has had its reputation you
know for being a violent prison
um
Through The Years you know it's it's
upheld its reputation
but
it's changed and now it's it's calmed
down so when the the violence really
slowed down I think is level four G GP
institutions would hear about a myth of
a level four uh lifer going home uh it
was a myth you know you wouldn't see it
and then BPH changed their their what's
been appreciated for a prison hearings
changed their approach on how they were
uh their Paradigm you know their their
Insight their insight and and so the how
did they change they were able to look
at the of the life of crime and then the
rehabilitation of the inmate while in
CDC to come down to their um
decision in regards to deny and how they
would deny an inmate
um
the possibility of parole or to see him
suitable
um for parole when I first started
working here
seven to life was pretty much life they
weren't going home I would say about 10
years ago is when door started opening
up of course now we have a whole lot
more self-help programs before it was
just aana when I first started that was
it
we have a lot to offer here now I've
seen a lot of inmates struggle with
their addictions and a lot of them were
struggling they weren't going home so
they didn't care if you know using drugs
was just part of their lifestyle they
were not a complete exactly you're able
to look past the worst day of their life
or the worst moment of their life and
you're able to see them as human beings
yeah and a lot of times I don't even
look to see what they're here for I
Don't Care What They're here for gods
are judged not me so as long as they
respect me I respect them if they get
into my programs I expect for them to
take it serious I'm not there to have
some [ __ ] program that you're just
going to talk about anything and and it
you know we're gonna we're gonna just
discuss the 12 Steps do the work yes I
should be strict with you no very she's
been Chief well you know what Mary's
she comes from the best places which she
has a great heart you know she's very
passionate and for her to say that she
cares about us that's not that that's an
understatement you know she really does
have a a soft spot for us you know and
uh she's she's seen a lot of inmates at
their worst you know showing up at their
worst but she's always been there as a
positive influence for us and a shoulder
to to lean on I had a really bad drug
addiction okay
um it took me a while to even uh have
the the
power in myself you know to to try and
admit that to my family
um
I made bad decisions I made bad choices
I was living bad uh I had a
destructive attitude
um it took me it took me a while to to
grab grasp a hold of uh some kind of
hope God God works in everything
you know he he makes he makes the the
bad that comes out of our our lives are
transpires in our life's choices he
turns it around for our good a question
I always ask is think about what you did
for your name out there on the streets
they got you where you're at
right
what are you doing for your name in here
to get you out about where you go
just a simple question
and that'll answer everything for you
and we constantly get involved in
disciplinary actions here constantly
going to add to constantly getting
involved in violence
well that that's self-investment whether
it's positive or negative right but if
you're constantly working to better
yourself right addressing
victim's impact you know addictive
personalities
then
then that's self-investment as well to
try to get home so the question asks is
what what investment are you making into
yourself and and your name a yard kind
of takes on you know the character
you know of the captain you know and at
the time I really came to interacting
with uh
hospital it was you know in the capacity
of him being a captain and I was working
in the program office and the culture of
the yard changed immediately for one you
know uh his accessibility to you know
making himself accessible to us you know
being approachable you know and then
when you go to them getting uh a
straightforward answer and follow
through either way if it was a year it
was a year and it came true and if it
was a no it's just a no-go so respect in
prison is it's a universal principle so
out there and in here respect is a big
thing but is it hard for you guys to sit
down with each other or not at all no um
myself and and may have had plenty of
conversations
um you know he was my inmate Clerk and
on my on my yard as when I was a captain
on sea yard and and plenty of
conversations plenty of conversations
regarding the up Alliance Group you know
where you have to Deep dive some things
even a conversation we had um last week
you know where you know he made a
statement in regards to you know I've
been sentenced to a walking death
sentence and my only question to him was
well
that or can you see it as that you came
to prison to find a better version of
yourself because where would he have
been if you would have still been on the
street still been involved in um illicit
gang activity or did you come into
prison to find yourself to find yourself
in a position where you know you're a
paralegal you know you completed you
know your education you know going to
college all these attainable and
achievable goals were those the type of
goals that you were chasing on the
street so the question is is did you
come to prison and find a better version
of yourself
you know and that's where the
Department's going right now did that
true story yeah true story yeah um and
I've had
many conversations with Acevedo where
that Paradigm Shift you know look at the
other side of the coin and I told you
this you know previously that I do
believe that you know this place
probably saved me you know just uh the
the path that I was on the way that I
was making my decisions the way that I
viewed the world in general and then
just um
you know having a victim mentality not
from the sense of you know I'm a victim
I need help but victim in the sense that
uh you know feeling like you're a
product of something rather than your
own choices you know the only thing I'm
a product of is my own choices Now find
myself in this circumstance
what do I do with it and the minute that
you look at your circumstance different
it changes just to change your
perspective change your circumstances so
we did have that conversation about you
know
finding a better version of yourself we
also had another conversation where you
know I felt like I was you know striving
so hard to to move the goal post for
myself on a personal level just you know
being seen for for who who I am and
um he said well you know basically it's
like you're screaming in the room you
know with the door closed you know you
need to find ways to to broaden your
yeah yeah Captain oswedo said that and
it was just you know light bulb above
the head moment where something turns on
it's like wow
a big part of why uh
I was um
doing the things that I was doing out
there when I was young because I didn't
feel the love that I was looking for
mom was abusive
dad's in here he got life
and
you know being abused as a child
it's like why is this happening to me
from someone that's supposed to be
protecting me
my mother was hurt
my mother was going through some issues
which I found out later
and um
growth for me brings understanding
so now I understand a lot of things
differently now
with the love that I was looking for
whether it's one two people my wife my
kids grandbabies and him like
other than that
I feel like that's all I need somebody
might say oh well I don't care I don't
need nobody but that's just the pain
talking that's the pain that they ain't
they having having acknowledged yet you
know because who wants to be alone man
nobody wants to be alone
like that's what makes
things more harder and difficult being
alone you know being buried alive and
you're trying to crawl back up to get
it's going to be tough yep it's going to
be we know it's going to be tough but
you got to keep crawling out because you
want that breath I ain't ready to go yet
there you go I ain't ready to let them
take it and that's why he that's why
when he always hear him when stuff get
tough and stuff get hard you got to do
the work you got to do the work but you
guys have been able to do is galvanizing
each other so through support to be more
accountable to live in service and
ultimately to live a life of peace and
hope and that that you guys really have
this hope and it seems to me like this
hope has pervaded this entire
institution laws have changed for sure
doors are open now that we're no longer
open there's programs on the general
population yard which would never around
but would you say that that assessment
was right on the role that the lwap
community especially has had in in this
prison
I would I would say we're the spearhead
of it because I said I consider this
sentence death by incarceration so when
you see the dead man walking with a
folder in their hands headed to a
positive whatever program NAA or you
know people constantly pulling up on the
elwop group and you see him just hanging
out within earshot now I can see a big
difference I mean every ethnicity
participates now and in the past not
everybody would talk right so it was
like um I've seen a big change and
they're taking it serious
um they want to be helped and so I see a
big difference now there's a waiting
list for every self-help program there's
a long waiting list reality is is these
programs and and everything that's
happening is a testament to the staff
the boots on the ground the people that
make it possible the people that allow
those inmates to come out of the cells
to go participate in the programs the
sponsors that sit here and interact you
know at a different level
with these inmates to create a positive
and uh on a strong culture here we see
the the end results you know but it's
those people that are working hard
diligently that didn't get an
opportunity to sit here behind this mic
or the camera sure to talk to you sure
because to them that's their everyday
grind yep you know and um and we only
succeed because they're out there
succeeding for us and putting in the
work and I would have never thought that
three years we'd be sitting here uh
having a podcast uh in regards to
um change within our facilities you know
but this isn't a test to the hard work
and dedication from the staff starting
from Administration you know from award
and allowing us to provide these
services and and again highlight the
fact that these inmates have put in the
work you know what I mean don't get me
wrong John it's uh dma has to put in the
work you know on the front end he's
gonna he has to want to change something
else that started bringing the change to
the yard is the fact that you know guys
like Ray started coming in here and when
he came in here he treated us as human
beings he said whenever I bring people
in here no matter what their Viewpoint I
just challenge them you know sit with
these dudes for X period of time and
then just tell me what your thoughts are
are afterwards just being in proximity
to us and you know for him to come in
and from the dribble
treat us as human beings and then see
that for the most part since Calipatria
has always had this this stigma attached
to it and then since you know the
elements and everything else make this
such an undesirable place for somebody I
mean
I'm talking to John Bernthal on the
podcast you know and for these things to
start happening and for the you know I'm
sure you see it the way you're greeted
everybody is just like man we're
starting to see the Hope come to life in
front of us you know and and it's
because people you know not just you
know thought about it they got off their
square and they did something about it
what you're seeing and what you're being
greedy with is people who who never
believe something like this can happen
happening in front of their eyes and
then you know by this happening then
what else can happen totally you know by
by this happening man maybe I can get
out of prison you know by this happened
you know maybe I can make my parents
proud before you know what I'm saying
before it's all said and done with I
remember when I first met Ray I told Ray
I said man you know you're doing
something awesome man you're doing
something great and being forgot about
is something that's going like damage
it takes a way to hope that and he was
like no man no no man I'm I'm not gonna
do that man can I swear he started
coming more and more and more and more
oh and I have
um we had it was the covert stuff went
on and I wrote him a letter I don't know
if he ever got the letter but I was like
hey man that hope man it's it's and
after that he was here and he's been
here almost every week after that so he
gives he gives a lot of hope he gives us
a lot of strength to continue and now
you
you're you're you're you're bringing
some some more feelings up up in here
man don't don't take this away from us I
gotta tell you the same thing yeah and I
know you're a busy man out there you
know what I'm saying but I I need you to
you know we all we all need this man we
all need this to know that there's still
people out there it's more people out
there other than our family than each
other that cares about what we are going
through the struggle
I would say for the people out there
that
don't know exactly what it is in here I
think that they should stop judging as
much
don't judge a book by its cover
don't think that change is not possible
in here
because no matter who you are or what
you're doing change is always there it's
on the individual if they want that
and it's a lot of us in here that wants
that first and foremost my God makes me
hopeful
um second my family
I mean I don't know how they do it the
support system that I have is is
tremendous I mean and I have a small
family but they're they're there for me
uh rain sleet or snow you know they they
don't stop you know the laws that are
changing now everything's everything's
more hopeful I mean I remember when we
didn't have as much hope as we do now
you know I would have never thought
having this in the beginning thinking
that out uh in the courts that was my
only hope
um but now just the laws changing with
the recision recitizen rate of an eloff
inmate getting out and not coming back
to prison that's huge
that's that's less than one percent you
know that means that if we get that
chance to get out
from the things that we've obtained and
hear from like people like Mary that's a
sponsor here
we're not coming back
everything that I'm doing in my life you
know is is a process of me trying to
live my immense I'm not trying to hurt
anyone you know
um
a a death
is something that intimately connects
people in a way that only people who
have experienced it will understand
and I mean they you know I can't speak
to anybody else's feelings but I believe
that I am connected to that family
forever you know and I will forever be
connected to that family because at the
end of the day every year
that day is going to come around and I'm
going to remember you know
um what took that what took place that
day and and and
understanding that a family suffering
began and the whole you know was put in
their lives that can never be filled so
you know we were talking about
what's the foundation and the found the
foundation is responsibility it's
accountability taking responsibility and
being accountable for my actions and we
were talking about the disconnect and I
wasn't trying to trivialize it but you
know
um not being the the actual Madness take
the life and you know being in a state
of denial but at the end of the day I
was a cog in that wheel you know had it
not been for me you know this situation
never never would have happened you know
and and so yeah I expressed what was
real to me I expressed what was honest
and
that's just it
I mean I think I know the answer but
what do you want the most for for the
Lop Community honestly for them to find
themselves
and I think from there their path will
be but that's what's most important yeah
that like I believe um
for the most part what you've heard is
that um they just been walking around
you know they I believe one person said
that they're The Walking Dead that
they've been sentenced to a life of
death I just I just truly hope that they
find a better version of themselves and
see that there's programs out there for
them and that participation
is them but they have to be willing to
take that first step forward and hold on
to something right and and start working
towards towards a goal you feel like
that's what's happening I I truly
believe that this elbow Community has
has come together
um and I believe that
you know you have every single l-wop on
that yard
that's that's involved one way or
another
their growth and their path is at
different levels and stages right
but from what I see from from the group
in itself it's like leaving No Man
Behind you know they see one struggling
they go pick them up we have our
affirmations and one of my favorite in
the affirmations is a show you show your
true character through your actions not
your words to me that's the most
powerful one and the one that I remember
the most because I I don't try and act
that I try and be that at all times you
know because the the other enemies that
need the positive influences a positive
role model you'll be seen you know we're
here with the same people all day long
and I'm I'm trying to do something
positive not just for myself but for
those that are in front of me and behind
me you know and to leave some kind of a
legacy for uh for the inmate population
that this is this is not the end of your
life right here you know I mean we can
uh supersede anything negative that
we've been through that we put ourselves
through that we can we can overpass that
you know and that's what the elbow group
is about to give us Faith and Hope and
and the curriculum speaks for itself
everyone out there you know can can
learn a lot about what's going on in
here and um do you guys find that do you
guys find that in life do you guys learn
lessons in here that you feel like apply
to the outside world is there something
that you really that you wish the
outside world would see about about
these places
I think there's Lessons Learned
everywhere
not not just in prison but anything that
if you take the time to really look
right and it gives you a sense at least
a minimum of sense to appreciate what
you have
and what you don't have what you can
lose
you know and I come back to it is is
that minimum understand that um
time is only thing you can never buy
back or get back
and if you want a lesson from prison is
that you know is that out of the the
population here how do they earn back
the time that they've been gone
whether it's a couple months whether
it's a year whether it's 10 years
whether it's 15 years 20. the One inmate
that told you he's been down 54 years
you know how does he recoup that time
and those moments because his moments
are in a card in a picture in a postcard
right but he's given those moments
through somebody else's eyes
so if anything it would be that message
you know appreciate the time
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]